good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and welcome back to my
channel welcome back we have a new setup
situation we're just like feeling about
the best possible situation ever since
the squatter took over our lives as you
know I imagine that I do and now that
we're talking about the squatter we all
saw yesterday that baby rat squatting in
a Starbucks cup we did is that a story
it's not a story today because it's
filth it's pure filth but I just wanna
like make sure we keep tabs on that
story because I want to make sure this
woman gets the settlement that she so
richly deserves I believe it was a girl
not a woman it was a girl he's a college
student at the University of Maryland I
don't know her name and I feel like it's
not our business but that picture I
posted on my Instagram story so did
Margo it is so vile so disgusting and
though the scariest part is that if you
notice basically this woman went to
Starbucks and found a dead baby mouse at
the bottom of her drink along with some
other trash that like went unnoticed
because like the dead corpse but if you
looked it looks like a receipt in there
or something
um the scariest part about the whole
thing is that the image has like a
virtually empty cup when you think like
did she drink the whole thing
hardly wants to believe she liked
someone on something was amiss and
someone on the scene who I know
personally now um told me that she did
drink the whole thing and she thought it
was ice at the bottom okay I missed an
expense but like a rat has a distinct
smell let alone taste I don't think she
could have drank the whole thing like
unless she doesn't have taste buds the
situation yes it's so disgusting and so
horrible and if the girls listening and
she wants to come on the toast like you
let me know girlfriend yeah but if you
are not gonna come on the toast because
you're in negotiations to get a
settlement from Starbucks I totally back
you and I want you to get at least an
eight-figure deal Oh at least figures is
10 million yeah I actually deserve one I
think she deserves 20 we're talking
about like what's the price of drinking
a rat 20 million dollars yeah because as
you know I'm close personal friends with
this are yes everyone keeps comparing it
to that story which for those who don't
know is a cover in the New York Post
what exactly happened um she was at work
she's my friend from college and she's
also like the best storyteller it's just
like a gift of hers so the way she tells
us right even cheat
via text and I was like on the edge you
said it's us I'm like oh my god I think
that's the worst thing that can happen
but this is worse Starbucks she was at
work she was actually feeling herself
that day like Shh shower didn't done her
hair fresh you know that feeling today
so she was shocked when like later in
the day she smelled really bad and she
looks like so self-conscious and she was
like why do I smell like I I showered
and I blew up my hair and then she like
there was a string coming out from her
dress so oh my god she went to like pull
it and it was a tail and did she pull
the whole mouse out um no then she took
her dress off uh and did you go home
from work that day I think she had a
change of clothes she had like a
demanding job so disgusting this is even
crazier than that
this is worse like by this girl ingested
it yeah so I really hope you got twenty
million dollars it do not take a cent
less like Starbucks has the cash to keep
you quiet girlfriend and you better just
do it and like if you need us to keep
bringing it up to get you that cash like
happy to do it happy to take down the
devil's brew any time any place anywhere
you know any time I like talk about a
business on my Instagram like in a
negative way like I do always feel
guilty like you know there I and I also
hate seeing other people do that like
I'm always seeing Kim Biermann tweeting
at Ulta about like how she was you know
disrespected kiosk and I just think it's
like the tackiest move ever so whenever
I do disparage your business on my
Instagram I really think of it heavily
like the only other time I can think of
as I definitely disparage my local illa
Molino restaurant but they [ __ ]
deserved it and honestly emiliano so
where's the most overpriced restaurant
of the city and I don't recommend it no
Starbucks really deserves it has like
the whole market their coffee is trash
everything is trying to except for those
Bantam bagels that we had when you know
it's like can you even have a Bantam
bagel I don't know my god was straight
from shark someone posted there was a
thread about this whole thing in the
toasters and someone posted they took a
bite out of their starbucks Bantam bagel
and it was mold no I just found out
about Bantam bagels I like them so much
I think I don't think it's buy direct
from you know I think it's sorry for you
there's a bantam store in New York
that's let's started that's how it
started so they're definitely the
freshest yeah but I feel like something
they were doing to them at Starbucks
like was so perfectly light no they were
freezing them and then they were
microwaving them I think the Bantam
store is where it's at we got to hit it
up I live for a bantam a go maybe we'll
say Bantam bagel so many times on the
show
they will just magically appear on my
doorstep matey and I do think they're in
the frozen food section so you could
make them at home
yeah interesante interest on but
nothing's ever better at Starbucks than
it is anywhere else yeah and a lot of
people were but I got a lot of jams
claiming that it was fake and I was
perpetuating propaganda which I don't
think it's fake but my question is like
how did it get in the cup because if you
think about how Starbucks tax their cups
you know upside down you take one you've
seen a drink being made obviously if
there was around there someone would
have seen it it's from that ice it's
from the ice right present and that's
why everyone always said isn't never to
drink ice like a dress sometimes a while
ago did an article about how dirty it's
like the amount of bacteria is equal to
a piece of duty yeah so like it was
totally an ice machine scoop yeah bye
we were scooping by skip is bad this
game and Shire scoop is bad giving back
also before we dive in I have to plug
something because we launched our Lauren
Elizabeth podcast on TNN last week and
she released her second episode and she
had Joey King as a guest and they were
just like two gal pals like sitting on
their couch drinking wine and I'm not a
psycho podcast lover which is crazy
because of the line of work that I'm in
but like I don't actively listen to
podcasts because you're always busy
recording podcast maybe but I get a lot
of podcasts like to approve or like
listen to preview and I usually will
give it like five or ten minutes but I
listen to like the whole Lauren
Elizabeth Joey King episode it's so good
at just dropped please head over I think
you guys will really enjoy it and Lauren
did some hard-hitting journalism about
what it's like to record the kissing
batil with your ex-boyfriend Wow yeah
and like I'm going to listen to it I've
been kind of saving it I want to be like
ready I was listening to that episode
and I was like wow we really discovered
some premium talent here but we do
discover her because she has like a
million YouTube subscribers but I was
like proud of us yeah Wow okay I'm
actually really excited to listen to it
today's a perfect day for me to listen
to it and I have a lot of things that I
would like to plug right now you've um
well where do I begin first of all I'm
on last night's episode of what are you
nuts
oh it's so funny you know what we were
did you turn to dry off sorry I know
this I know this but Ben didn't say
anything to them it's great I think he
still doesn't know he doesn't know but
like we record in your house all the
time that you always turn the dryer off
yeah where we move into the bedroom I
didn't notice it and I'm sorry but
anyways we did it and I was like no
one's gonna relate to I didn't watch it
I didn't read the comments and then
later in the night I did and people were
really on board you know what are you
nuts is taking the world by storm
like when Ben started he bought a tripod
es Lauren Elizabeth like what ring like
should I get him like are you kidding me
but I have to say I was wrong to see
this picture of him setting up in my
house I took a picture of him and it's
so funny
wait oh god wait hold on I think it's a
hilarious premise and people come up
with the most like random people come up
with the most random like things I take
them off and it's actually quite
relatable and I really enjoy it
Ben lunch a new i G TV series called
what are you nuts and it's like two to
three minutes he sat down with me and
the Jackie and I guess he's gonna have
to find someone next week who's not in
our family to talk about the rat but it
was right after you guys recorded
what're you nuts I was like oh yeah
buddy nuts and then he's like how did
this happen but they're doing so well on
Instagram story so I got actually I'm
proud of Ben I think it's a really good
idea and it's getting it's super cute
second plug is that we are on today's
episode of the bio files yes we recorded
in LA which is very exciting
third plug is an exciting thing for the
campers because the snatchler is coming
back the podcast sister is coming back
in a major way and this is not our CNN
announcement no no no this is just an
update
she's coming back she'll be dropping
every Tuesday so the first one will be
this Tuesday November 5th what are you
gonna be covering and so basically
during the height it's still bachelor
podcast but in the hiatus like as much
as I would wish so there's enough drama
to talk about for 40 minutes there's not
so part of it will just be like classic
bass or drums and then it'll just like
be about the snitch in my life and I'm
gonna record it with my roommate tonight
see if she can do it like she either
really can or really can't it's gonna be
great Nicole I had a lot of faith in her
I don't know it's like I want to know
what you and Nicole talk about in your
apartment and that's what you'll be
doing - Nicole really all we did was
just it on the couch and talk so I'll
just put a phone there and just keep it
there is majors drums with the whole
Timmy I know you're gonna talk about on
the stand yeah but I just want to say I
said it first like I knew they were
broken up yeah yeah and you were right I
just won't say like I love hearing your
take on the bachelor world but I'm
really looking forward to hearing about
your life and your friends and what you
guys do is 23 year olds in New York City
like oh it's so exciting at the peak of
your life in the greatest city in the
world like no one else has a podcast
like that what is it like let us in I'll
let you in but I'm just saying I also
want to appease the people who are just
there for bat agree of course because
you're a woman who can do it all your
business what your tell you building
audiences yeah so let's see okay and I'm
just really excited as like as your
camber I'm excited to listen to it and
know what's going on in your life
finally yes but that is not our TN
announcement our TN
TNN it out so it will be on Friday we
are launching a new show and I was
taking a buncha guesses on Instagram and
nobody guessed hit but I guess it's like
why would they be haven't like really
spoken about it like at all usually will
I drop a hint and it's like super and
not subtle no there's no way anyone
would or could guess this but it's
really good but it's really good I'm
excited to share it and to listen to it
so it's gonna launch on Friday and I
think the first episodes coming next
Monday right yeah very exciting stuff
exciting times over here at you know
more exciting stuff that I would love to
promote is girl no job comm we're
heading on the road we're going to
Toronto this weekend unfortunately it
sold out but I did launch six new shows
the magic tickets available Verona New
York Tarrytown work tearing cities
already any New Jersey please no but
these are such excite I think I know
them all by heart now let me tell you
them oh sure
Verona Tarrytown and Atlantic City New
Jersey and this city
Englewood Kansas City Turning Stone turn
those stones out turning stones is
Verona or Tarrytown I forget which one
what's the six Ontario yes I already
said that you didn't okay
Ontario Atlantic City Englewood Verona
Tarrytown and Kansas City I can be some
reason for this six shows like when I've
had to record Instagram stories when we
launched him like I picked the six most
random cities in the entire universe
Tarrytown like and I can't remember them
tickets available out girls no job com
also I did release my extra tickets to
the Beacon Theater I'm pretty sure
they're sold out yesterday after I said
it but check it out
Ticketmaster go with no job Tom love you
guys can we see you on the road see you
soon Toronto Toronto it's just an
exciting time to be a toaster I feel
like there's so much like happening like
I feel like what usually when the show
ends like it's like quiet go back to
work Sally by the water color but now
like you have so many more things you
can be doing oh I thought you meant for
us like when we first started this it
really used to be like toast we would
work on the toast like an hour or two
and then like pretty much just like live
our lives now it's like I was up working
till 11 p.m. last night
no same like between like merch TN and I
said sure they merged shop yes I'm so
excited it's sickening I'm ever since I
started watching YouTube videos I have
like literally started talking like a
youtuber literally a bed that came home
and I'm like I literally was like been
that shirt the house like I need rocks
Zach came home and I was like hi how are
you that is probably like the phrase
that I have like a debt like that really
takes on like its
like in in integrate into your own life
I walk onstage I'm like hi how are ya oh
my god that's so funny recap the two new
episodes at the end of the show plus
Real Housewives of Orange County but
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast just in case it
didn't honey don't
that's true you know some would say this
time and and I don't disagree but I
don't necessarily agree you know what
I'm saying because if I did agree I
wouldn't have the opportunity and the
privilege and the honor to let everyone
know that today's episode is brought to
you by 3rd love literally the back
saving Brad that chick no look I'm sorry
I mean their third love is the backbone
of this show truly like it keeps these
chi Chi's up as two three actually
enormous Li breasted women finding bras
that support and don't break your neck
are truly it's a journey and it's taken
me almost 24 years to come to the
conclusion that their love is the only
bra for me so third love uses data
points generated by millions of women
who have taken their fit finder quiz to
design bras with breast size and shape
in mind for a perfect fit and premium
feel third love offers more than 80
sizes including their signature half cup
sizes you can skip the trip to the store
find your fit with third loves online
fit finder order and try on at home no
more awkward fitting room experiences so
I think I realized that part of the
problem with having big breasts is that
you never actually know your size and I
didn't realize that I was wearing like
the wrong cup size and band size it's
like literally my whole life so just
there's so much value in knowing your
bra size and for some reason they could
find out from a quiz but your bra size
is boiler alert number 36 J it's like
mortifying excuse me yeah I just danver
knew that you just be me shaming no yeah
are you here this what says of you I
think I'm a 34 double D nice what are
you 32 F we're a big titty committee and
that's why this episode is brought to
you by third love take their fit finder
quiz it only takes about 60 seconds they
have a perfect fit promise every
customer 60 days to wear the bra wash
the bra put it to the test and if you
don't love it you can return it and
third love will not let it go to waste
they will wash it and donate it to a
woman in need their team of expert fit
stylists are dedicated to helping you
find the perfect fit their hands down
the most comfortable bra alone I swear
by it the straps are not tight the wire
does not
into your armpit it is truly the best
bra and they give back they donate all
their gently used returned bras to women
in need supporting charities in their
local San Francisco Bay Area and across
the United States so far they have
donated over 15 million dollars in bras
which is amazing third love knows
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they are offering our
listeners 15% off your first order go to
3rd love.com slash morning toast now to
find your perfect fitting bra and you'll
get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love thi Rd l.o.v.e comm
slash morning toast for 15% off today
less dine on thank us later yeah for
real you guys also before we launch into
stories I just wanted to wear uh but
something I was on Kim's story last
night oh my god just kill me okay and
this time it was different than me
dancing around in my skivvies which was
exciting because you were wearing birch
which was less genius business move ever
thank you I also just wear murder on my
house every sin today also merch is
available at morning host calm and while
it is still available it really won't be
for long I'm watching these inventory
number two if you want something you
should get it right now Jackie may be my
favorite activity is the Shopify app
like watching our inventory numbers go
down it's like so exciting it's like I
imagined it up you'll feel like when
they you know bet on horses I'm like Go
Go yeah no it really it is exciting and
it's also just educational we were
learning so much about the tutors and
what you guys like yes so most of the
items are sold out a few of the
accessories are have like very low
quantities left and we're not gonna be
restocking them because we're doing a
big holiday launch anything that was
like back-to-school specific was just
for the back-to-school drop so that
won't be coming back to school yeah so
shop morning chance calm before they're
gone it'll probably be cleared out by
the time holiday drop rolls around so
don't don't get left behind y'all don't
don't do it no don't get left behind um
sign out and smell amazing Wow someone
in the comments just call me out for the
way that I drink like so much backwash
I have two things to say I'm not sharing
a beverage or that he wants to like that
my backwash my business - I'm wearing
lipstick and a Geoffrey start lip gloss
so excuse me for not wanting to like
suckle my lips into the bottle I put my
mouth around it like a penis
also like it's your life do whatever
it's you live what you gotta do the
world is watching you every day the
choices you make say what you are and do
your heart beats for it's an open
it's your that what she can do the
worlds as well she knew it's never too
early for a little Christian music gonna
in a big Jewish Franchesca bout a sound
we live for a test that album was really
formative like changed my knees get it
on vinyl yes good one that's one of
those albums you would put on it like
any song like really lifted your spirits
I ordered Jesus is king on vinyl from
the merch store okay I don't need to
talk about the merch store like the
prices oh my god also he charges the
prices that he charged so he doesn't
have to go on Dancing with the Stars I
yeah right and I guess I RS is taking
50% of the pie and you know what I've
never related to a lyric what song is
that on God and it's the best album IRS
takes half of the pie that's what I
charge what I charge so my kids don't
starve and I ain't dancin with no stars
meanwhile Kim did do Dancing with the
Stars so like he's [ __ ] her - but
that's cheating his own way peace saying
like she there was a time where she
tried to go i Dancing with the Stars but
now like they're charging the prices
that they charge know that prices are
crazy but like I've been to the day
there's so much demand for it like
that's just pure capitalism and like all
the power - yeah but my parents are
crazy but there were t-shirts that were
160 dollars sweatshirt is crazy yeah but
there was stuff that was less than fifty
dollars which is like the Jackie I read
that's craziest wheat does he get
tax-exempt on his merch because he's a
church oh my god yeah I think yeah like
a 501c3 you have to get like you have to
get approved by like the president to
get tax exemption remember probably
definitely could but do you remember um
like two years ago
Scientology Trump like he was wanting to
revoke their tax exemption and that was
like one thing like everyone could get
behind yeah yeah was I want to follow up
with your favorite loser he called tax
exempt Oh such a good question I don't
think so because they weren't claiming
to be religious they were just claiming
to be like downtown for losers
yeah oh yes to like get better at that
being less loser I guess someone
suggested a brilliant TNN show for us
what like you know Chrissy Teigen has
like her show about like regular crimes
like we should have like a loser on
loser crime court okay that was the
conversation we had on the show what
yeah and when you talked about like some
of the loser he crimes we would
prosecute we did yeah we would start
with an axiom
we said then we would obviously have
like Caroline Calloway and I don't know
what the third one was but that was not
a toaster suggests and that was like a
conversation that I participated in okay
I was just reading the TNN comments last
night
maybe they thought that we went forward
but oh maybe yeah also update I did
secure the username at toast news
network thank you to the toaster who
works at Instagram for helping me out
with that um you're no longer toast dot
news network I'm also working on
securing at the snaps lawyer because
it's underscore this now it's
embarrassing it's unacceptable
and you know whoever is the snatcher
right now will appreciate that it's not
effective like that's why the person who
had at chose news network I feel like it
was someone who like when we launch
toast news network like why would
someone have that like you know also an
update about my pursuit of jackieo
handle someone commented in the toast
like the real Takeo is the toaster and
she's waiting to get into the group I'm
like I know that she's not because I she
doesn't follow any of us but I was like
okay what's her name but turn out the
handle was at the real jacket which is
not a handle that I want but anyways a
toaster made it into the group I'm sorry
anyone who's not to offend anyone at the
wheel jackieo but if your username is at
the Rio there's nothing real about you
sweetie
but it's like at this point it's funny
no it's a it's a parody and I always
read it's Ariel Ariel I love it
yeah yeah okay now I guess it's time for
the past five stories and the first
story was a last-minute addition because
I didn't realize what was going on here
because I stopped getting the paper
because I didn't pay my bill it was also
like I didn't want to make my veil
yeah no it's a fun activity hey no I
didn't have to people injured are named
like [ __ ] you right it was just I was
feeling better I will probably
eventually Rios or this story as people
we're like constant getting slandered in
the media it's like hard for me to like
keep up with media because I've refused
to support any of the outlets that write
mean things about me so I'm literally
left with like radar online who has a
lot of respect for us and honestly like
TMZ they're not terrible US weekly dance
weekly no it's not even that I don't
want to support them because they don't
like us it's like they write falsities
about us so I can't trust anything else
that they're writing they could just
blazingly right these falsity and also
I'm bitter that's part of it too yeah
like how can I support Rupert Murdoch
when he literally had a hand in you know
writing a slide
Duras article about me okay but then on
the other hand it's like say they didn't
write about you our job is like
public-facing
so that means you're like a nobody
nobody cares about you that's like the
hardest part about like this whole thing
it's like all i really want in this
lifetime it's like to be you know so
famous so like for just like making
people laugh like in a positive way you
can't do that without being in the paper
i know and you can really only be in the
paper for being controversial so like
any time I've ever done anything
positive or like philanthropic like
nobody gets [ __ ] it's like I fart the
wrong way and it's like oh my god Taylor
Lautner like New York Times article like
I can't even live no but it's like the
paper it encourages people to be
negative because you get written up when
you're negative we do so many positive
things like someone write up camp toast
it's the coolest [ __ ] thing of all
time oh yeah
so come to camp toast you can have a
whole bird say to yourself you have your
old bunk
you can only bunk if you want to come
report on the magic that goes down at
camp toasts yes any reporter here well
here's a decree official no but you have
to come from my collegiate newspaper
that like come at the top of Google any
reporter that who's whose masthead falls
in the first two pages of Google will be
inclusive gets a free ticket to camp
shows if they want to write up the magic
of to camp toast and their own bunk yeah
email hello at morning toshow calm yeah
serious enquiries only yeah and this
isn't a way for like someone to get a
free ticket like I know just to write it
up on their blog no but blogs don't
count first few pages we will be doing a
background check when I search news on
to Google your publication has to come
up as the first two on the first two
pages yes I think that's fair I think
that's really fair but anyways back to
the news famed pathologist Michael Baden
says Jeffrey Epstein's death was a
homicide shot
honestly it's shocking that someone's
admitting it you know what's shocking is
that it came out it's like if you're
gonna go all the way to kill someone
cover it up you know ya know but they
didn't have to because they just needed
him dead and I don't think we're gonna
get close at all to finding out who
killed him but at least now we all know
that we're not crazy
for knowing that Jeffrey Epstein did not
commit suicide not crazy he was
definitely murdered it's just so crazy
because I feel like the Jeffrey Epstein
saga was like such a big part of like my
life and like it really took over the
news when it was happening and like the
second he died like people stopped
caring
no and we knew that was gonna happen
which is why it was so frustrating yeah
I just forgotten this show we made a
commitment to continue to update people
so that like the story wouldn't slip
through the cracks but like it did you
know it didn't we didn't because how can
you report on the dead person you know
right well didn't we think he was like
still alive
yeah oh there's theories that he's you
know in Nicaragua or something and he
wasn't really murdered it was like a
body double and we just like I think
what we said at the time was like it
goes back to like whether he was a good
like people enjoyed spending time with
him like because either way they have to
get rid of him but if they you don't
even really like the guy just killed him
but he runs in high places who really
enjoyed him and like enjoyed his company
in like maybe want to have dinner with
him again then maybe they snuck him out
yeah but I do think he's dead
New York's former chief medical examiner
insisted Wednesday that Jeffrey
Epstein's death was a homicide honestly
he sounds like a toaster forensic
pathologist dr. Michael Baden was hired
by the pedophiles brother Mark Epstein
to observe his autopsy after he was
found hanged in his Manhattan lockup in
August quote I think that the evidence
points towards homicide rather than
suicide the brother is concerned that if
Epstein was murdered than other people
who have information might be at risk if
they think he has information his life
could be in jeopardy
I guess the brother well maybe now his
life is in jeopardy not that he's like
bringing it all back up yeah I mean how
much did they pay off do you remember we
were talking we were just talking about
like how much do you think that coroner
had to have been paid off right so now
like let's go back to the coroner who
obviously like filed a report with
falsities right um where's the justice
yeah let's let's trace the money
American greed like we need you on this
oh my god I would just feels like
everyone's not working hard enough on
this I went on LinkedIn for the first
time in years
what and I checked my messages and I got
a message from the producer of American
greed and this is so American greed they
messaged me on LinkedIn to have like the
producer of the show come on the toast
oh but I never saw it because I wasn't
on LinkedIn I finally responded but like
I mean like it was when we that week
where I was talking about Americans I
just got into it it was so long ago but
if you're watching again an American
great American greed we would love to
have a producer on the show so we can
give you some suggestions for episodes
we want to say honestly I would really
like a nexium episode that doesn't you
know focus so much on the loser aspect
one more so I'm like 150 million dollars
that that woman what Claire Bronfman was
was funneling I want to know more about
that yeah America focus on the money
side and that's what we got to follow
them
here where was the coroner on vacation
recently honestly it must be the money
it must be um anyways this like feels
nice for all of us who already knew the
truth yeah I just feel justified and
it's nice to not feel like we're being
crazy conspiracy theorists it's crazy
when like your conspiracy theories are
um like alluded to or even inferred in
mainstream media it like makes you feel
so see and like something about the
whole Anthony Bourdain thing just like
didn't sit right with me and like every
now and then there is an article about
like how weird it was and I'm like thank
you like we're not all just gonna
pretend to live under a rock no everyone
is like happy to live under this Anthony
Bourdain rock and that's one of those
things where I do feel crazy for
thinking what I think so I know yeah
it's like 30 kids literally walking the
earth who just think like anything
Bourdain like tragically committed
suicide yeah when it's like that's so
not the case where is it it's not and
I'm not gonna hang my hat on that one I
mean either but it's it's weird yeah
it's just more suspect then then they
would lead you to believe I agree okay
next story we're gonna lighten it up
with a little like mindless celebrity
news thank God I just love some mindless
Sorella celebrity news and this is a
group of people who are just taking over
the tour just mindless who are taking
over the celebrity news and I don't mind
it because it's mindless Brody Jenner
reportedly splits from Josie Kinetico
Cancun say go and say go Canseco crazy I
mean not that crazy but cool like I it's
weird I was just gonna say I could say
my thoughts I don't know I only chose
this story because I do have one thought
because I was thinking about it when I
heard that they split up and I kind of
been shipping
Brody and Kaitlynn guy I was just going
to say that Oh same 100% like they had
to stray to find each other yeah like
and I loved them on the hills they've
been separated for at least like six
months now she was with Miley that
didn't work out he was with Josie and I
think like Josie he was just like this
is exactly what he wants a young girl
who just wants to party who's hot and
just like will go to the club I'm going
up on him about having kids and go to
Jewel every night with ya but he did it
and it's over and I guess it wasn't what
he thought he wanted maybe yeah and I
think that it's time for him and Caitlin
to get back together they both had to do
their Wild Oats and so that they can
like go on the hills and give everyone
fingers yeah I mean that would be ideal
um I I ship them as well I really just I
started watching the hills somewhat
recently and followed Caitlin Carter on
Instagram and she's just like a paid job
so I think that Brody's one of those
guys where it's like as much as the
hills was fake like who he is is was
very much conveyed like bad boy that's
are like never gonna settle down and
it's like the most eligible bachelor in
the world and he also doesn't really age
physically so he's just like the
best-looking guy yeah now so it's like I
don't think that's hot anymore like I
actually think that's really a
responsible and stupid of you know and
like the more you talk to people who are
married um the more like you learn that
like marriage is a wonderful thing and
it's like only then do you realize like
oh you were wasting all your time how
does he not see that he needed to talk
to us I think yeah he doesn't listen to
our podcast with Lea Michele where we
just talk about how wonderful being
married it is and are also our podcast
with Nick vile where we tell Nick vile
about how wonderful benighted is and I
don't I think he was like shocked when
he heard us say that that were just like
these boring old women yeah but it's the
best time of life it's the best we are
in the prime of life but so nobody like
me here at this show but then 22 year
old the Snatcher living it up in New
York City also the prime of life that's
true it's a different kind of what about
Snitch Jenner with Brody I know we say
snitch Jenner a lot because I handle him
I don't think you could either and also
he's not Jewish she would have to be
like a snitch genestein Jenner Berg
Jenner Berg I love it Jennifer gentlemen
um also it makes me sad to think about
it's Brody and Kaitlynn are together
will she will she so be on the hill he's
the connection to the hill Hills and I'm
sure they could have I'm sure they would
have offered her a place to stay but I
don't know if like being on a reality
show is like her life's dream know as
iris know and like Nike has to go with
her tail between her legs and like
Spencer gets to breed her I don't know
if he's gonna sign up for item I hope
she does and I think she could take it
me too um but I also would love to see
them and get back together and I just
wonder if that's even on the table I
wonder too like they're both single
maybe they just needed time to explore
they ran into things a little too fast
but they'll find their way back to each
other and I think there's something
really beautiful about that but like we
also have like no it doesn't say
anywhere that this is even on the table
but we are putting it on the table yeah
no we are setting the table I grab the
placemats grab the cops paper napkins
let's [ __ ] go let's so I can go and
we have to put it on into the universe
you know
manifest destiny ask believe receive
okay look special this third story um
I'm just loving because John Legend and
Kelly Clarkson are reimagining baby it's
cold outside without the controversial
lyrics oh my god it's that time of year
again where this story comes up and I
like roll my eyes not to always bring it
back to glee but I am watching Glee and
they do the Christmas episodes and that
song is a conversation and I listen to
the song and I sometimes I'm like people
are not it's like this song is just
totally fine
and then sometimes I listen to a song
and I'm like you know people are on to
something you know there's something
weird about the song yeah well I love
this story because one we're getting a
Christmas song from John Legend and
Kelly Clarkson like I [ __ ] Stan - um I
do think the baby it's cold outside
like controversy is just like a
hilarious controversy and I don't really
fall on one side or the other and three
now they're gonna put this thing to bed
finally right with a proper rendition of
the song and it's reminding me of Kanye
now is changing the lyrics to some of
his past songs to be more like g-rated
and in line with his message now and I
think it's like a cool thing to do in
general like why should you be singing
something that you felt 10 years in jet
like we're something that we felt
60-year that was ok to sing sixty years
ago that's really like not okay to sing
now yeah change like why should we lose
up it's a classic song right yeah no
this is I mean obviously the best part
about this is that we are getting not
only a duet between two iconic singers a
Christmas duet which who could ask for
anything better
John Legend and Kelly Clarkson have
collabed before so I'm very much looking
forward to this but now we're just gonna
put this this worn out argument to bed
like this argument has almost become
political ya know it is political but
it's also it's so but not you know
because it's a song so it's like even
it's you can argue really I just I buy
it like I know I mean I don't like that
although there and then there's a part
of the argument that people are
forgetting which is like this song also
just sucks like melodically it looks
like a [ __ ] annoying yeah yeah also
what people are forgetting it's like
it's a song like if you don't like it
like just turn it off yeah look that's
my whole thing with like politics these
days like there are people like who
don't agree with things other people do
but like why can't you just like have
your own opinion
like I didn't like it's just like okay I
don't agree with like you but like like
that's not my business you know what I
mean like everyone's just in each
other's like pants these days yeah it's
like everyone just stay out of
everyone's business okay well I want to
recite some of the new lyrics oh I would
love that so it says I really should I
sing it or should I sing it sing it I
really can't stay baby it's cold outside
I've gotta go away I can call you a ride
this evening has been so bad you dropped
in so very nice time spent with you is
paradise my mother well I'm [ __ ] it
up my mother will start to worry I'll
call a car and tell them to hurry so I
guess it's the now and advertisement for
uber literally and I just like this
anyway like but they're changing lines
that were not problematic this evening
has been so very nice glad that I don't
know maybe that whatever the man says
after was was not good I don't know
whatever I'm looking forward I hope you
get a music video and it's know it's
like updated version updated for the
time since it was like she's gonna walk
home in the snow like you call number
right that was also really interesting
about the youtube series which we'll
talk about when they were doing the the
shade names there were so many things
that they couldn't do like they had to
call it diet cola when he kept saying my
uber Sam like that's never gonna fly
right cuz of you know it's like he knew
he wasn't able to use Tanic on uh yeah
but they were being funny about that
yeah but she doesn't trademarked anicon
I don't know it maybe she trademarked it
for an event but not as a makeup company
maybe um I also I don't think they
really care about like and also it's
like cool for her that she's part of
that it's all good I feel like youtubers
like aren't litigious they like
appreciate the promotion yeah I need to
go back and read the original lyrics of
baby it's cold outside because like to
me it's just like a guy who like doesn't
want a girl to leave in life right so
that's where okay read the lyrics
because people are saying it's about um
like date rape yeah and I just want to
get clarity but very much can be about
date rape and it very much can be about
a couple falling in love okay a guy who
doesn't who's being annoying and doesn't
want a girl to leave and it's like I
just wanna like go home okay this
evening has been so very nice I'll hold
your hands they're just like ice
without consent my mother will start to
hurry beautiful what's your hurry my
father will be pacing the floor listen
to the fireplace roar he's just trying
to convince her to stay
so really I better scurry beautiful
please don't hurry so maybe Jesus
annoying she suggests well maybe just a
half a drink more if she wanted to stay
he said but like teach she would say
what or was she just being coerced yeah
um the neighbors might think what's in
this ocean then she says say what's in
this drink and then he says no cabs to
be had out here oh hostage ok wait what
does that mean what do you mean that she
can't he's telling her she can't get a
cab so she's like hey you gave me a
drink what's in it things are getting
weird I mean this is the second verse is
where things get loud I say really
[ __ ] weird it to break this I wish
you knew how to break this spell that
could be likely drug I'll take your hat
your hair looks swell he's taking her
hat off I ought to say no no no sir mind
if I move in closer I'm sorry no means
now no reason no means no [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of my face and then
she's gonna say at least I'm gonna say
that I tried
that's a weird lyric yep the whole thing
is weird ok I take back what I said
there's really no like - I simply must
go the answer is no the welcome has been
so nice and warm my sister will be
suspicious my brother will be at the
door my maiden's aunt mind is vicious
well maybe just a cigarette more ok this
guy's out of control that's the point of
writing this song like it was like
supposed to be cute yet but like I guess
it's just didn't I don't know when will
this spell if you dress your rv's this
is my friend this do drugs well he wrote
it some old timer yeah teen Martin was
he the one who was living in Canada
until he was an idea that's James yeah
is the one by now that's like shits made
my core the most and it's also like the
one I believe through and through I
don't know why me to him so yeah I've
actually never taken a hard look at the
lyrics and maybe people are onto
something with their outrage yeah yeah I
know I think Kelly Clarkson and John
Legend are are doing it perfectly
because like the song is you know
classic it's been a part of like the
holidays for so long it's an infamous
duet but it gives like people a pin and
it's [ __ ] weird um and they're gonna
put their own spin on it so that we
could put this argument to bed and like
now this version can play on the radio
and hundreds in your forum is a perfect
perfect solution like usually there's
like arguments and there
never solution yeah no this is
definitely like this is piece of the
Middle East for sure can we talk about
the voice coaches like being best
friends like I feel like Kelly Clarkson
got thrown in and like she really
shifted the dynamics of the entire group
and like honestly away with Adam Levine
I think he was like thought he was too
good for everyone it's like we've got
Kelly Jon and then Blake and Gwen and I
like Taylor's a mega mentor like there's
just like this camaraderie and I don't
even watch avoids just like seeing all
their interactions on social media like
I'm very much like wanting to watch it's
like almost getting me I know I'm gonna
watch because of Taylor she's on this
week's and next week so four episodes
which is like a million hours of my life
but I'm gonna watch and I just like the
when I watch it it's a great show it's
just such a big commitment huge like two
hours twice a week yeah I'm speaking of
shows that I don't watch Dancing with
the Stars you guys see what Hadden Brown
posted
do see Tyler sees comment what did he
comment he was like you fall down seven
times get Becky let me find it basically
she got like negative feedback for the
first time and like felt like writing a
caption about it when like Allie Burke
and Lorna Lee and I've been out here
like getting criticism all season but I
don't know what it was that Carrie Ann
Inaba said to her because I skipped
through the judging oh my gosh basically
I guess that Carrie Anne was like pretty
harsh on her what did she say she was
really one mean well like she was like
borderline mean and like Len was like
that was amazing blah blah blah and then
Carrie Anne was like basically saying
that like she feels like a disconnect
like that she's like holding back or
something she's just like being really
like she's being really harsh on her and
but I think what made her start crying
and that was fine when her start crying
though was after the group number which
is like the group is being judged not
one individual person they called her
out again and was like you were
connected they're like used to have to
stop being so insecure and she was just
think he was just like why call me out
right now again in front of everyone and
then she started crying and it was like
a thing and I know this is an unpopular
opinion but like I just I can't help but
roll my eyes at this it's like she has
had the most like amazing she's beloved
by the world like everyone like loves
her and think she's like America's
Sweetheart and she's probably gonna win
Dancing with the Stars and it's now what
week 7 and she's getting her first piece
of criticism and like she feels I need
to write a whole essay about it it's
like when she says the essay which is
what we said yesterday is that
everyone's progressing and she feels
like she's falling flat
she's the best answer and she's gonna
win well anyway he commented fall down
seven times
you got this hbb where your feet are and
enjoy the ride you're doing amazing now
he's like not too good for anymore being
a fair sponsor okay well here's what's
happening because when his season ended
and he was saying gee he couldn't do all
he's like you know thirsty little press
opportunity said like that come with
being part of our nation like ads and
podcasts and whatever and now that he's
no longer with GG like he can do those
things but it's like a little too late
for the rest of us and it's just reading
his thirst yeah I'm sure he's a nice guy
but it's like uh - like he got a facial
yesterday and like had till I post it
and I was just like stops weren't like
on the same level yeah that's cool okay
next story Game of Thrones prequel is
dead at HBO this is like so sad because
these prequels were the only thing
really getting us through the whole
finale but there is another one there's
the other one they picked up House of
dragons and they cancelled what's this
one um this one is agent no no this one
was untitled there this prequel that
they decided to go with sounds amazing
so I'm not even mad at it's the prequel
it's like 500 years before game ends and
it's the how the Targaryen rise - which
I would love to say I'm so glad that
they're folks on the Targaryen I don't
even care they could have focused on
literally the inside of brands butthole
and I would have been happy like I just
I can't believe we're getting a prequel
like you hear about these things but you
don't think they're right it's like
produced by george RR martin and miguel
the guy who does who did all of the good
episodes of Game of Thrones basically
just a new Game of Thrones right yeah
look people are gonna be just as like
standing and I hope so I think so yeah
okay so this one was supposed to be
about the first-ever battle between man
and white Walker which Ike really
doesn't sound of the white walkers I
don't want any good if he has a royal
drama like like you know the princes and
the princesses and the [ __ ] and the
who's the dad you know like that's what
this [ __ ] I enjoy yeah no I totally
agree the supernatural elements like
really don't get I supposed to be like
the children of the what - no and I
heard that one of them is supposed to
focus on bran the Builder like their
ancestor who built the wall maybe that
was why I needed a wall when he first
met a white Walker I'm sure it's gonna
be great but who loves the first white
Walker how did we all felt like the
night king was like someone who's
literally nobody he thought it was Aerys
Targaryen yeah yeah
we never he found out that it wasn't
right but why he died yeah yeah
interesting I'm so excited for this like
we need Game of Thrones right yeah bro
it's not a great
bro it's not gonna be here for the next
three years that's true but it's good to
have stuff to look forward to and you
know what three years like flies by when
like Joe Giudice is in prison for us
right that's true and it's like life
life just like that we were doing our
show when season seven in Game of
Thrones ended and we had to wait like 18
most two years for the new season I
thought that was never gonna come look
it came in when it came in with what
really hit me was it was a episodes like
the early seasons of Game of Thrones
where it's not so much about White
Walkers and people's powers and bran
being a raven really just about like
life in the new earth you know politics
with the south and then the capital like
that kind of stuff I find so interesting
almost more interesting than like the
supernatural elements and I do wish the
prequel was like more of like a the
crown you know the crown is interesting
it's just like royal drama ya know I
don't know that it isn't so I'm have
high hopes I'm just excited for us to
like stand someone again like Daenerys
you know what I mean yeah and just like
to watch smart television because I'm I
love like all the dumb TV that I watched
like Game of Thrones was really just
making me think yeah and I just think
making us like better like a show that
makes leaders run around no yeah I say
Game of Thrones is over of all eight
seasons all the characters who came and
went
who would you say was your favorite
character ooh
I mean I look like knowing how they all
turn out maybe for me Terry that's what
I was gonna say oh yeah because it's
like you like people but then like you
can't get behind their decisions because
they're still [ __ ] stupid Jon Snow so
it's like I loved him and I would have
said him but he was such a bad decision
maker and then I think about the whole
series like there was no one I was ever
really angry with like they were always
on the right side of history
Tyrion maybe that's why he won the Emmy
four times yeah yeah I would
like it's you want to say someone said
but like she was the [ __ ] well my god
then at the end I got so self-righteous
ya know at the beginning with Joffrey oh
my god no yeah she was the worst I think
she was my least favorite and it's so
great because like Sophie Turner's it's
like this she's so different now like ya
know she learned she learned
okay Sansa walked so so we can see the -
Tori is a really interesting bit of like
cultural television
Netflix is experimenting with letting
you watch movies at 1.5 times the speed
so you can speed up the binge process
like how people listen to podcasts at
1.59 this is so crazy like we're robots
yeah no we're out of controlling judd
apatow is like picking up the torch of
people who are so against this i kind of
agree i kind of agree too it's like
what's the point in putting like
millions and millions and millions of
dollars into like an art for if you're
just gonna find ways for people to
consume and get rid of it passer yeah
and I'd like what it's long with you
know but you would still be able to like
you can watch however you want but it
would offer this option which a lot of
people do like for podcasts and YouTube
clips right well I guess this is kind of
just like copying the pod and I know a
lot of people not for our show listen to
other podcasts on 1.5 speed just because
like Millennials and people our age like
we consume things faster than the
average person so having a podcast on
1.5 like to me that doesn't seem
disrespectful I think people actually
put us on point two-five but I just for
some reason this this comes up
disrespectful to me I don't I don't know
how I feel about it because I learned
form yeah but it's like I wish I could
watch the affair on 1.5 times because
then maybe maybe I would get through it
okay but that's like a really standalone
like that's that's the news oh why can't
it just be an OP I'm not saying that I'm
here for this but it's just an option no
one's forcing you to do it they're not
like and a lot of people would probably
not do it but some people might want to
get through things faster this just
seems like an excuse for bad TV like
good TV I always wish is longer like
when there's an episode of Housewives
that's really good like I want it to be
longer not shorter so this seems like
we're making excuse for putting out bad
content that I could do better things
that is an interesting point that it
would like encourage people to just
speed things up and then they'll be even
more goofs because like you don't notice
it yeah you just be more caring less
more like shitty edits a guy could now
I'm like such it from watching friends
like they have so many production errors
like mouths mismatched to audio like
just place cups like I just noticed it
also like I'm a really loud like a
learnin TV watcher um and this would
just I think you know encourage more
flubs that's it that's a good point I
don't have a horse in this race but
Netflix does because then people would
watch quicker and then they would
more but it's like but no really animals
hissing you know this is black mare and
I do things like yeah the whole like
binge-watching culture is so crazy that
like it's in current like it is so
normal for us and I this is how I spend
every single weekend like to just stay
home all weekend and like binge watch a
TV show and just like not leave your
house and not have any sort of social
interaction except with the guy who like
delivers our food right but like but
numbers you know that would have been so
frowned upon and they're like really
Tetra mental for your mental health like
it's not good to not leave your house
and not talk to anyone no like now you
know sunshine that's my TV's dying when
it's like there's one episode per week
it's like how how do I do that I don't
know how people used to watch 22 minute
episodes of friends every week it's
crazy but like that's what people did
because they had a life they're like oh
let me just catch a [ __ ] right drinks
with Sally yeah it's really crazy but
it's interesting watching jeffree star
Shane Dawson because they talk so much
about how they don't leave their house
and I'm like I thought they were joking
but I don't think that they are
Jeffrey's like I mean Shane was like
Ivan left my house since last time I saw
your office yeah I don't think he's
joking but then I was watching Jeffrey's
snapchat last night and he was saying
that he's like going out he's like
Jeffery stars leaving the house everyone
like I mean is it a internet personality
I guess you go on the internet because
you're an introvert and introverts don't
want to leave their house right that's
true and but and then the people who
find success they build themselves big
houses that they really never have to
leave yeah and maybe then it comes with
like being famous you really don't want
to leave your house yeah interesting
very I don't know why I don't leave my
house well I don't leave my house
because my house is my office it's my
home it's my safe space and it's my
son's like playground like what really
what do I need and I also don't leave my
house because of the traffic and when I
go and do something like it infuriates
me like to the point of like rage issues
that I'm just a much more peaceful
person if I stay home or only go in like
walking distance I'm so susceptible to
migraines outside the house I rarely get
migraines in my house you know what I'm
the opposite I only get my like when I'm
just like chillin I get a migraine
no but and then when I go and do
something and like I distract myself
that my green goes away Oh opposite for
Ray interesting okay can we recap real
houses of Orange County mhm
Shane Dawson and I think that's it yeah
what do you want to start with Orange
County that's good by the way it was
actually pretty good episode it was an
incredible episode we're three
for three right now that [ __ ] lunch
was out of control kind of so [ __ ]
stupid um I like she looks like Mad
Hatter Alice in Wonderland but before we
start like are you and me out here Gena
defending again because I can't no she's
so wrong like something yeah I am out
here both sides of the coin defending I
see both it was loser loser crime for
sure and I don't like Stan Brennan
enough to like really take a side but
Wow Gena was being so [ __ ] mean she
totally took a what Bronwyn said out of
context I before she even said it like
all the ladies had a reaction to being
like oh and your kids are in public
school right and I do you think part of
that was editing like where everyone's
like but I didn't think it was so crazy
and I actually thought what she was
gonna say before she said it I was like
their archi are more like developed
programs in the public school system
than in most schools and I believed
running when she said she wasn't saying
in a derogatory way no because and it
was all just about perception like Jena
obviously has some sort of comp plan you
have and took it in one way but yeah
Bronwyn said in like oh and they're in
public eye so I totally saw both sides
but I also understood why Gina might
feel some type of way about it like
maybe it is a sore subject for her no
but like Gina's just so [ __ ]
self-righteous she's like the only
person who's ever gone through anything
and everyone in the world needs to skate
around every little thing around her
it's like going through okay like you're
getting divorced like it's sad for sure
but like you'll be fine no but it wasn't
until this episode that I realize like
the magnitude of having like three
little children and what that like means
for her and how much she must have on
her plate and now like helping her
children like develop like this is a
really important time in their
development and like if she's not there
for everything which she can't really be
because she's everything that's going on
in her life like it's a lot on her plate
and I just I didn't realize that aspect
everyone has like do it for the kids do
it for the kids but like demons
she has like a lot on her plate that I
didn't see but she was the youngest kids
by far and she's doing it alone and it's
definitely difficult but just the level
of like inference she was making like
when Bronwyn got up and then Shannon
went and by the way I appreciate Shannon
being good friend Shannon was a very
good friend this episode um when she
they both caught up basically she was
like I mean Brahman literally just said
like because I'm poor my kids don't
deserve a good educate like that like
that sort of translation it first of all
is so dangerous and that it's the cause
of most arguments between most people um
but such like such an unfair lie
conclusion to jump to yeah and then even
when Brockman came back to apologize
when I didn't think that she owed her an
apology at any she should have just been
like you totally misunderstood what I
said I'm really sorry like that's not
what I meant but like Bronwyn came back
to the table with her tail between her
legs when Gina was one who a blew up and
that reaction was totally unwarranted
and B Gina was the one who took her own
insecurities and misconstrued what
Bronwyn said yeah and then if I were
Bronwyn like after like being like I
didn't mean it this way it'd also be
like but now I'm pissed at you because
they could to figure you to put these
things in mind telling me a snob like
yeah and by the way I'm sure she
inherited like her time when wanting a
cup like who cared it was Bronwyn said
it perfectly like Brahmin said I might
be a Sami [ __ ] but in that moment I
wasn't being one yeah and she's like and
I can take it like if you're going to
tell me it like I'm I will totally own
up to it and like that's the value
that's where good housewives are made or
broken like when you could acknowledge
your own faults so but I think in that
moment they really both did because then
Gina like was like listen you didn't do
anything wrong it's the way that I react
like I don't open up and when I do I
don't want to hear anything about it um
and I like you didn't do anything wrong
it's just the way that yeah and I
thought the way that it was resolved it
was like a great fight because it was
really all there yeah and then it was
resolved swiftly yeah Bronwyn just like
can't hold her own she just immediately
starts crying she was like shoving that
napkin in her eyeball so hard but you
know was very interesting about the
whole fight is who stayed completely
silent was Emily I just thought that
like I mean and her friendship with
Sheena is definitely really weird and
fractured and I think her being super
quiet or not even you know like moving
over the other side to like hug her you
know like was was telling of the
fracture in their friendship um and then
even in her commentary she wasn't even
defending Gina she was just like Gina
anything Bronwyn says Gina's gonna want
to bite her head off yeah we should also
might be true but it's like it's not
fair to like just lash out at people
like that how annoying is Vicky um like
shut up oh my god like just be grateful
you're filming rocks I know but she was
actually being pretty funny this episode
in like pretty middle of the line like
wasn't even offending anyone and they
really want to talk about Tamra and like
after this episode I don't understand
how she came on the show and goes I'm
watching happens live and says she
doesn't know Mike at least I'm with her
1,000% at the same time here's my only
Tamara was being a complete shift
starter like and she did two things this
episode that were [ __ ] starter e1 in the
car being like when she said you want to
go to
like okay you're not that good of an
actress like of course you knew what you
were doing and there was one other thing
that she did starting the pot in the
beginning of that so I thought that it
was really her in chatting where who
were trash-talking Helle yes and calls
Kelly's like everyone said but he
brought in the wonders of bending Kelly
and like diffusing the situation and
saying no it wasn't that big of a deal
when they were saying she broke her
wrist she got into a fight and broke
fight like she has to stop doing that
and then they go and call her like I
thought that was like what and I felt
bad for Bronwyn like being in that tough
spot to defend someone who everyone's
talking [ __ ] about and then to have them
go tell the person they're talking [ __ ]
about don't you hear the one telling you
[ __ ] that was crazy thank you for
reminding me um oh and by the way I just
want to say I know I said before that
Bronwyn has been spineless before on the
show but I thought she was very spiteful
this episode and she defended Kelly even
though it wasn't like the way she was
talking about Kelly wasn't the popular
way to be talking about her no it's like
before that I think she was spineless
because she had nothing to fight for but
now that's what Kelly really has been a
good friend she shows his eyes and now
she's gonna fight there's no reason that
she should be a piece of [ __ ] and get in
on the conversation like yeah I heard
Kelly did this at a bar like no she's
not an [ __ ] yeah also I find
bronwen's family life it's so
interesting like how many children she
hasn't like she literally has kids in
college and a topic Tubber like a
newborn it's crazy it's crazy but back
to the Tamara thing so was the saying
she had those two egregious crimes
um and I'm looking forward it looks like
in the next episode everyone's pretty
much putting the pieces together
um I think Shannon like what collages
her head like she she knows that's what
Tamara does but like doesn't want to
hold her accountable for it but like
Tamara hasn't done this in a long time
this is like this was so crazy yeah this
is like ogee housewife uh [ __ ] starting
maybe housewife [ __ ] starting 101
literally maybe it's just that like
Vicky has been you know demoted they're
really feeling the pressure and like
Tamara September just moved into a gated
community and it's all because of the
show and like maybe now it's like
kicking in that like Tamara could be
next so she's really kicking and kicking
it into high gear and trying to make
herself in disposable yeah and I
appreciate that I would just and I
understand if she wants to bring
everything to the surface and like train
funeral etc um but don't then pretend to
be big Kelly's best friend when you are
throwing her under the bus left and
right this season oh that's what I
wanted to say so yeah it was like really
like stupid of Tamara to be like oh I
forgot
I've said that but Kelly did say it on
camera so at the end of the day anything
on camera whether whether or not someone
goes and runs to tell the person they
said it on camera so it has to be told
you know what I mean yeah that's like
whenever was upset at Bronwyn for
telling Kelly what they were saying true
it's like me saying on camera so the
person who you're singing about is meant
to find out because that's how the show
works that's true but I just thought her
delivery was like really like accuracy
like her pretending like you know just
be upfront like if she had done it not
in a way where she was pretending like
she didn't mean to say it like I
wouldn't have been so upset about it
because you said it on the show and now
it's it's fair game just like oh yeah I
hear that
but why did Kelly say that like they did
have just made up I actually understood
where Kelly was coming from because it's
like we made up I will film with her I
will go to these events but I'm not
gonna be her best friend again and I'm
not gonna celebrate her birthday I come
I think that was like the most rational
thing and I love how everyone was
calling her to come come and she did not
come and like I feel but I see that like
we can we can film together we can sit
next to each other we can have a good
time together but we're not going back
to that level and no I don't want to
celebrate your birthday and I think
that's so fair I took it like let's do
extreme but that's Kelly
but that's Kelly also like what was but
it was like sad watching Vicky hear
about her own funeral yes by the way I
thought the exact same thing because I
think everyone like is self-conscious
about it but I think when you get to a
certain age like you think about it a
lot more per se like you're just
thinking about your age and I just felt
like it was top of mind for she's having
like a mortality realization and like
that comment just she liked it she
didn't even react so crazily other than
saying Kelly pushed her mom down the
stairs she just like was heartbroken you
know you could like her voice was
tremoring it but it wasn't a kelly thing
it was just like realizing her own
mortality thing yeah it was actually
really sad I thought the exact same
thing
yeah yeah it was a great episode it was
a great episode you guys this season is
crushing it I find the Vicki Tamra and
Shannon to be like I would not want to
be friends with them like they're so
cliquey like they didn't really even
tell anyone about the costume thing like
that's so fun and it's not nice like and
that's where like I'm sure a lot of the
divide in the group comes from like just
insecurities like well why didn't I get
invited to go to the costume store like
if I was even like [ __ ] Broadway and
like why not yeah or Emily like Jeana
tell her the word dressing up yeah and I
thought Emily looks right for a tea
party yeah like not a stupid costume tea
party but like a lovely afternoon tea
yeah it was out of control but it was it
was a great episode there
more and more clicky and I find it to be
annoying especially because Vicky's not
even a full-time housewife yeah
but they are kind of funny as they trace
it of course but like Gina is trying to
be the claw charming guy I'm not here
for it interesting
okay let's also recap the last two
episodes of Shane Dawson Jeffrey Stehr I
completely agree with you that the
second to last episode that we just
watched was pure garbage strike one
really nothing happened but I understand
the needs to be slumped like every movie
you know they have to break up before
they got back together and have a happy
ending um but the way it was edited
where it's like okay I want to focus on
Morgan because I think this is
interesting to you and I want to hear
more about the influencer so you want to
hear about the palette why did they wrap
it all together like you're not Scorsese
also they're not going chronologically
anymore and I find it to be really in a
way and if I could just make one request
like I don't need to see you know him
seeing the palette in October but then
also the last time he saw it in March
like and then back to Morgan and her
influence returning yeah I'm in back to
Andrew getting his makeup done and then
Shane in the gym and then the doorman it
was just a copy and I don't like that
format then I'm sure it's like a style
it's one I just I find really hard to
keep up with that very much prefer the
chronological order it's easy and I want
to see the process like from start to
finish and not start finish and then
back to start and then one more time
back to finish and then in the middle
one more time like I just want to see
the chronological occurrence of events
but having said that last night's
episode was very interesting they
literally they posted to like almost 8
o'clock Eastern Time and it was almost
time for Real Housewives of Orange
County and I was like getting so cramped
but they posted it like 8:30 and I
watched it and it was super great um
Andrew who's the cameraman I needs to do
two things for me his laugh is annoying
and he needs to stop I find he's on
sounds like Bronwen and two he needs to
get a tripod or something because I get
nauseous watching he's always like
throwing the camera he was going really
crazy but though yes in a conversation
like yeah you just back up and get both
of them so you don't have to go yeah I
agree
but the palette I like being made it's
actually kind of crazy like how
last-minute things are like with the
with the packaging but I thought where
they ended up was really cool and
beautiful and definitely fit into
Jeffrey's aesthetic and almost like
looked like too similar to some of
Jeffrey's palettes but it felt like a
jeffree star cosmetics
product yeah I agree it days came out
really cool um I don't know what I was
expecting though you know I wasn't
expecting that I they just talked like
it
the editing is so dramatic like you're
like it's gonna be made of diamonds but
it's like
it's just a makeup Ella you know yeah
and it's like the same sort of box has
blue blood like yeah it's really not
that crazy but I guess it's not supposed
to like change the world it should
supposed to be on brand right and they
still have to keep it at a certain price
point so like it really can't be made of
gold right but we got to see the fill
palette now obviously are you gonna get
anything um I really will watching the
episode last night really
I felt like annoyed that I miss out on
merch like they didn't really promote it
so much so unless you're like Shan fan
following him on Twitter I don't even
see half the products until last night's
episode um so I do wish it I'd gotten
merch I don't know if I need I just got
the entire jeffree star collection
makeup so I've like every blue blood
palette I have everything jawbreaker
I've two jawbreaker I was like I don't
really need another palette okay you
hadn't gotten that box with you got it
of course because honestly the palette
the shadows are very toned down like
they're not crazy jawbreaker I just got
like it's crazy like neon pink yellow
which I don't really use so I probably
would have gotten the same thing because
it's very like neutral tones yeah I
don't know like I really want to get it
I but I just don't need it like I wear
like one eyeshadow color and that's it
is beige like I never wear eyeshadow
which is so crazy because I now have
like a crazy collection of eyeshadow but
it's like not about needing it I don't
know and it's like no one is gonna use
every color on that palette it's a
really weak crazy industry we're really
just buying something it's almost like a
collector's sort of thing it's it's so
strange because it's like I know I'm not
gonna use this but I want it did they
say how many units they had order total
about a million I'm a million of all
three products oh I think that without
send the lipstick bundle I think that
was every all in you meet you it's a
million units 7,000 fit 500 I just want
to know like I'm sure it'll sell out
because honestly I don't think a million
is enough and that's what Jeffrey was
saying last night just given how big the
um serious ask are like and you and I
didn't even know about cheating right
Chinese yeah I wasn't thinking about my
good I probably will die how it's like
it's AI and buying a palette everyone
who's ever loved him and loved Jeffrey's
fine and I was a twenty five million
subscriber Shana and Jeffrey is like 15
yeah and these videos are getting like
20 million views yeah and like you have
to take into account like not everyone
is in the time a place where they can
purchase one right now so out of the
twenty million people watching I would
say like very conservatively at least 5
million people want to buy something
yeah that's so crazy signature are you
gonna get anything I've
watch it yet oh my god I was talking to
her about that yesterday cuz I was like
turning on my TV at home and I was I
gonna put it on she hasn't seen any of
it
I plan to I just like haven't gotten
around to it it's a great plane
documentary to watch yeah I just yeah
watch it on the plane because I was
getting really distracted because then
everything that they were doing it was
making me I was like oh let me check my
merch I was like wait let me go to his
Instagram I want to see when this I was
on Morgan's Instagram looking for this
Hawaii trip what brand was it okay it
was brand list because um or it was just
like I don't know what it could have
been but she wasn't tagging any brands
dude she's really good flow that Morgan
she was really cute I wish a focus more
on that because I couldn't understand
what Jeffery I couldn't comprehend
what's the word it wasn't he was saying
anything on not understandable I was
just like in a million different places
I couldn't seep in what he was saying
this this these tips and tricks about
the industries about giving advice but I
forgot because five seconds ago we were
talking about his dogs yeah I was just
ashamed of that Jim yeah but it was it
was interesting like I want to hear
about these influencer trips but now
what's super interesting is that the
episode we got today had content in it
from October 22nd which was literally
less than a week ago so the palates
launching on Friday I'm assuming our
next episode will have content from the
launch like they're gonna really because
it's not over it's nine parts right and
we only got five episodes so far oh I
don't know or six six so hopefully we'll
have an episode with the actual launch
and I want to see numbers they've been
so transparent with like quantities
money like I want it all yeah I I was
doing the math um and if they sell out
it that's like about 50 million dollars
Wow um
and what did what was their their
breakdown they never went you know they
did um I think it was 20 or 30% for but
that was for merch I don't know for
merchants that he gets 72 yeah Shane
gets em yeah and then for the palates I
think she might be getting thirty well
he should because literally Jeffrey's
doing everything Jeffrey such a good
friend
I need a [ __ ] palette it's heart it
was tart what was true and what was the
brow oh that's so interesting think it
was the the Hawaii trip that Morgan took
according to Margo it was a tart okay so
on 50 million dollars he would get 15
million that's so crazy well is that
after costs no it's not so I don't know
yeah cuz like that's gross sales yeah I
mean it's just so crazy like Jeffery is
really doing everything like shane has a
couple ideas and I guess at the end the
at the very end he came up with the
design for the palette but did he really
because that girl got box sent the box
with the triangle on the top so Geoffrey
literally has done everything Geoffrey's
team like it's so crazy he's just doing
this for Shane because like he likes
change you know what I mean like it
could be anyone
but it's also great for Geoffrey like he
like he said he's never sold this amount
of anything so I think it's so mutually
beneficial and Geoffrey is making more
money than yes but it but Geoffrey's
literally doing everything like every
time he comes to Geoffrey's office or
Jeffrey's house there's like a million
new things that Geoffrey did that he has
to approve
yeah but Geoffrey would be doing it for
himself so to have Shane and what like
they said it it's like an album you know
and you'll have your best hits it
broadly it really is like an album yeah
so to have his catalogue to work with as
opposed to just doing like another theme
like he's each bringing a lot to the
table but I like this is Geoffrey show
and I I need a reality show about
Geoffrey right that's what was so
frustrating about this second to last
episode was like it's Geoffrey's show
and Geoffrey wasn't even in that episode
was all about let's chain bettering
himself which like I guess is
interesting but chains a documentarian
like that's he's more behind the scenes
I feel like ya know he was it wasn't for
me personally yeah that episode um also
oh I meant to say in other episodes like
truly Geoffrey and Nate our relationship
goals like oh I know oh my god I love
their love it's so their whole life is
it's together is just so beautiful so I
was saying and how hot is he he's so hot
and like me I forget what they were
doing but I was just like oh my god
they're perfect like I just I love their
love me too you know he lives a life
like she plucked Geoffrey plucked him
out of obscurity in Michigan and now he
lives in a palace in Calabasas like down
the road from Kim Kardashian she buys
him and she was just I just watched a
video where she bought him like a neon
green Aston Martin I don't know I keep
referring to her Geoffrey Geoffrey has
the [ __ ] sorry Geoffrey if they talk
about Kim and you know yeah I was like I
was confusing my they get along Geoffrey
just bought a neon green Aston Martin
for Nate he just like lives the life
likes most wheat in Calabasas and like
has the best life yeah and has like a
skate park in his backyard right and is
a skater and it's a dog dad but then he
was also with Geoffrey since like before
there was a brand so he deserved like
you know you just loves him for him yep
I let it
and now Jeffrey like took in his brother
their brother Zach works for Jeffrey
he's one of the videographers and lives
in the house I think crazy yeah I love
it I really do need like more just like
Jeffrey's day-to-day yeah well I just
watched one of Jeffrey's old YouTube
videos where he was testing the new
Urban Decay mascara that claims to be
sex proof so he put it on and then when
had sex with Nate and they came back and
it was like tears satis eyes was
actually hilarious that's proof but he
said he did like the product that's
really funny yeah I once I'm done with
the series I'm gonna dive into some old
videos I'm really just loving watching
YouTube videos on my TV meet you this is
Jess lebarge and this is the exact point
Jeffery is doing this for Shane because
of what the first series did for Jeffrey
it's like the first series Shane did for
Jeffery like he I think he totally
revitalized his business like I think he
changed his life forever and now as a
form of repayment he's gonna do the same
for Shane yeah while still also getting
great press for his breath no and just
like he's gonna make Shane some serious
money yeah it's awesome it's awesome and
I want to support what they're doing and
that's why I want to buy it because like
but they have this support and then I'm
just gonna have more makeup in my house
that I don't have space for no total so
I don't know what to do and that palette
doesn't staff yeah so it's she's gonna
sit there it's gonna take up a lot of
space maybe I'll get the mini
controversy yeah um I like those colors
too some nice blues for the snaps are
they're doing a mean green at the Mall
of America in Minneapolis and like I
look you want to go like it's gonna be
like if they're gonna sell that because
it's totally full circle because it was
Jeffrey's meet-and-greet now it's morphe
yeah yeah which is such a cute way to
end it yeah really cute living for it
can't wait for the new content their
stuff drops Friday which is also the
same day as our new tan and show
announcement so make sure to follow to
news network on Instagram the morning
to--some Instagram Jackie yo problems on
Instagram girls no job on instagram at
margatroid on instagram at pub with no
job oh so tomorrow is Halloween we have
such a special episode for you guys I
think it's gonna be really fun yeah it's
gonna be hard to get our seats will do
that today
thank you guys so much for just hanging
with us we hope you enjoyed today's
episode thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the Millennial
morning show where we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe do
the little bell leave a comment give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast but you obviously
know if you're listening to us as a
podcast right now we're available on
iTunes
if I stitcher Public Radio cashbox I
Heart Radio anywhere you can listen to
podcasts so feel free to subscribe and
leave a review subscribe subscribe we
love you guys so much have an amazing
day
you